Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 25th.
Could you hear me looking for the date there?
I kind like was looking and I,
June 25th,
sorry.
I'm actually excited because I'm doing it Sunday night.
So this fucking thing is going to be up at midnight west coast time in the
continental United States,
which means I don't have to deal with anybody,
you know,
giving me Shit Dude.
What the fuck?
You know what?
What the fuck right back at you.
I'm going a great God damn move my Lady Lady.
You have left this state and I am all alone low now.
And I'm remembering what it was like.
Are you guys single man,
I just made my freckled ass so motherfucking chicken.
I had Bolus.
I deboned those thighs to like a motherfucker.
I'm such a stupid move.
I A hit.
I had boneless chicken breasts,
no boneless chicken thighs.
Um,
and brought Brock.
Sorry,
I can't say that word without,
I can't say Broccoli without a,
an Asian accent.
I don't know why.
I know why.
Because when I lived in New York City and I was broke,
there was a Chinese restaurant around the corner and I always ordered chicken
and Broccoli.
Okay.
If I wasn't eating sketti with fucking Prego,
I would call up.
Every once in a while I would treat myself with little Chinese food and I will
call up.
They like hello,
number one.
I'm like,
Hey,
number one,
what's up?
Can I get a good,
I get chicken and Broccoli.
They made chicken and Broccoli,
chicken and Broccoli.
And ever since then I've said that she'll just in case you thought I had any
Chinese blood in me,
I don't.
I consider those people,
my friends for all the chicken and Broccoli.
They made me back in the late 90.
So sounds like an apology.
Like a corporate apology.
I had no dealings with number one Chinese food.
Uh,
I did stop in there on a number of occasions.
I did partake in some of the cuisine that was offered,
but at no time was there any inappropriate touching underneath that filthy
fucking glass that I don't think was bulletproof.
Okay.
You know,
I'll tell you the Chinese restaurants in fucking New York where I lived anyways,
when I was on the upper east side,
Jesus Christ.
You know what I mean?
It was like you'd have some either was either rusty,
rusty,
great between you and the other person,
or just filthy
plastic or some shit.
I Dunno.
Why don't I don't,
oh Christ.
I don't even know what I'm saying.
Look at my dog.
Just fucking lay in there.
Can you,
can you get a God damn job and con,
you know,
contribute.
I'm actually jealous.
Thanks.
Fucking skinny as hell,
dude.
But dogs umay she ate it.
Dropped her off at the trainer.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Yeah.
What were you,
what were you doing over there?
All right,
let's,
let's get the podcast.
Let's get it.
Let's get it back under control.
I didn't do shit today's anyways,
so my woman's out of town,
my lady,
she's out of town.
So,
uh,
you know what's funny is she keeps checking in on me.
You know,
what do you do?
And let's go at odd,
you know,
and you know what it is.
It's one because she misses me into because they think that we're fucking morons
and she just wants to hear.
I like,
Whoa,
what a difficult time I'm having without her,
you know,
like,
oh,
I don't really know how to make cereal.
Like,
like I'm some Sit-com fucking guy.
All right.
Start.
I was going down.
I did the fucking laundry.
I made myself a healthy dinner.
A protein,
no bigger than the size of my head.
Isn't that what we supposed to eat?
And uh,
in some fun.
A vegetable.
Okay.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You know what?
I had a great time doing it.
I haven't cooked in years and you know why?
Because my woman is oppressive in the kitchen.
She loves cooking.
So anytime I go to cook,
she comes in there.
She's looking over my fucking shoulder.
Just why are you cutting them up that way?
Why don't you then you're like,
uh,
fuck it.
You do it.
You fucking do it.
Why?
I'm
fucking trying to make you a goddamn meals.
One of the nicest thing somebody can do for you,
prepare a meal for you.
Just sit there.
Shut the fuck up and let me do you think,
what do you think I did?
Eight and an eight on a god damn garbage kids before I met you.
She just gives me shit about the way I make my eggs because she,
you know,
she always says,
I always like whenever I make scrambled eggs or whatever,
like there's too much egg gets stuck to the fucking pan and it's a pain in the
ass to watch,
to wash.
I mean,
you know,
it's like,
I'm sorry I don't spray it with,
you know,
fuck the ozone layer Pam.
And every goddamn time dripping with the shit,
no wonder it doesn't stick.
I'm surprised it doesn't spark it.
Slide right off onto the floor.
This is,
but you know what?
This is what this,
you just listening to a pathetic man whose site that he's finally in his place
by himself and he can just deliver his entire argument without being
interrupted.
So,
uh,
I'm telling you,
she wants to come back and as much as she wants the place to be neat,
she wants it to be a fucking disaster.
She wants to feel needed.
She wants to feel that I am fucking lost without her and I'm such a cunt.
I am not going to let that happen.
This place is going to be spotless.
It's going to be ready for one of those movie drill sergeants.
You know those guys that get in your face,
hey,
you know,
you can come over here and bounce a fucking quarter right off my goddamn face
ever.
Whatever the fuck they do off the beds.
So he's very,
today I wouldn't ever make it in the military.
I'm supposed to be able to bounce the fucking court.
Why?
Why you supposed to be able to bounce a quarter?
Why does that somehow make me uh,
you know better at fighting the enemy?
If I can throw dirty change at a blanket and then to then catch it like the
fonts,
you know,
what happened to you sir?
What did you really want to do?
Get?
Oh,
did you really want to do this and scream it p that was your,
that was your dream to scream at people for your entire fucking life.
That's what you wanted to do
with that Hitler Fade.
Do you know Hitler had like a fresh prince from Bel Air Haircut mixed with a,
uh,
Martin Sheen in apocalypse.
He was Martin Sheen,
apocalypse now on top,
but he had like,
he had a fade down below that,
that will Smith's character with the eight ball leather jacket.
What would would've loved?
You would have loved it.
I'm sorry.
I've been watching a lot of shit about fucking mass murderers lately and he
always comes up,
of course.
You know what I mean?
And have a think about mass murders without Hitler,
right?
Just can't fucking do it.
Can have a rock show without Zeplin man,
stairway to heaven.
You know,
that's what he is.
You got to fucking have that shit in there.
So I'm,
so that's my goal.
That's my goal.
And I'm actually wrestling with this.
Should I leave the place a little bit dirty?
So she feels like wanted.
Well,
should I just be,
should I just go fucking like,
you know,
just come with the pimp vibe.
Like this place is fucking spotless.
All right?
So you need to be on Umi.
Need to mind your p's and q's.
Whatever the fuck those letters stand for.
What does it stand for?
Somebody going to know somebody actually knows what when you don't,
when you say mind your p's and q's,
there's some Douche.
Listen to this.
Yeah,
you're a dose.
All right.
That knows what the fuck that stands for.
And they've just been waiting for somebody.
You'll fuck it up.
All excited so they can be like,
I know what it means.
We'll send me a god damn email.
And by the way,
I haven't said the email for awhile here.
Oh,
what a segue.
Fucking classic right there.
I should teach a fucking podcast class.
Uh,
you know somebody's going to do that.
So I always get a podcast class the same way somebody teach a comedy class and
that's what you do when you're failing.
Whenever you're failing at what you do,
you teach it.
All right,
there we go.
We just insulted teachers.
Um,
all right,
the email is bill@themmpodcast.com.
Bill at the capital m,
capital m,
capital P odcast.com bill@thefmpodcast.com.
All right.
If you don't fucking know what it by now,
just hit stop and rewind on your little player and you'll be fine.
I'll buy the base.
Can you guys,
uh,
I know,
I really appreciate all the input and all that stuff that you guys sent to me
because God knows if he didn't send it to me,
I wouldn't be able to do this podcast.
See,
without you,
I'm nothing.
As they slowly dim the lights and I go into some sort of pandering fucking song.
Okay?
Like that Jackson Browne song singing about the roadies.
Like he gives a shit,
you know,
I think he fucking pissed them off and they weren't set in his piano upright.
So he wrote him a song just so they stopped fucking with them.
So he get where of his tour and then somehow he goes out of that too.
Just fucking,
the whole thing is,
I hate pandering.
Okay.
I don't like,
and you know,
the only,
not the worst part of pandering is watching a performer go on stage and pander
to the audience is watching you fucking animals.
Eat it up,
eat it up.
Every God damn time
I go to jail.
You Sob.
Do we played a lot of cities but Hartford,
you guys,
you guys are the best and have way
and me a fucking break.
There's nothing good about Hartford.
You know,
you don't believe me?
Ask The whalers.
Why do you think they left?
You couldn't even hold onto the fucking whalers.
How does that make you feel?
Hartford.
You know,
why they left?
Because that's stupid ass song.
You splay.
Bam,
Bam.
Pepper paint.
What's it called?
The,
the,
the brass city orchestra.
Um,
speaking of sports,
I think,
I think my good friend Paul versus,
he's a little upset with me.
He's been on this Robinson Cano thing.
I swear to God since I've met him.
Okay.
And,
uh,
he,
he's a,
he's the,
you know,
he's the classic dude.
I called it guy and uh,
he,
he got it.
He called me.
We actually,
he's brought up Robinson Cano to meet so many fucking times,
like a year or a year and a half ago.
I told him,
Paul,
like,
I actually put like a gag order.
It's like you have to stop bringing this fucking guy up.
You're making me hate this guy and I don't hate him.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what he said six fucking years ago whenever the fuck Kano came up.
But Paul Versey believes that he is the only person in America that realize the
potential of Robinson Cano.
You know,
and let's just say for the sake of fucking argument he does.
It's fucking seven years later
know he's like fucking you don't either.
And then,
and then he's got all these other calls that,
that,
that fell on their fucking faces.
Right.
You know what he's like,
but all he does is bring up this Robinson Cano.
Shit,
I'm getting sick of it,
Paul Versey cause I know somebody emailed you this fucking link.
All right.
You know what you're like Paul with your predictions.
You like Jerome Bettis at the end of his fucking career where he'd have 15
rushes for 22 fucking in the fourth quarter,
just totally getting shut down.
And then he bust off one for like eight yards,
10 yards,
and then he would get up thumping his fucking chest like he's been doing it all
day.
That's what's bugging me about this.
He called me up,
this is how fucking sick Paul Versey is and why you should see him in a comedy
club because you have to see his sickness life.
He called me up,
I'm sitting on the fucking couch,
might,
you know,
might have my own fucking business hanging out with the dog,
making sure the place is spotless.
So when my woman comes home,
she knows I can,
I can take your fucking leave your mind,
your fucking p's and q's Lady.
Um,
he calls me up
and I'm going to break his fucking balls about this.
He called me up and he goes,
dude.
He's like,
I know you're not going to give me credit for this,
but this one might be my greatest call of all.
He's talking about the Robinson Cano thing and the way he said this might be my
greatest call of like,
he's looking back on this hall of fame career as the dude.
I called it guy.
If I told you some of the shit that this fucking guy throughout their,
you know,
dude,
Matt Castles,
the real deal telling you
the chiefs are for real man.
The fucking for real
Vince young.
Vince young was a winter man.
All he does is when,
who else?
I can't even fucking remember.
Lebron James.
He's,
he's afraid of the moment.
The guy is afraid of the fucking moment.
I actually,
I don't know shit about hoop.
When he took one,
Lebron James took that last second fucking shot,
all right.
Against the Celtics and he missed it and it went into overtime.
If forget what fucking game it was five,
six or something like that.
Um,
what was it?
Was it five?
No,
we won't get five.
I can't remember what it was.
Game six or something?
No,
not game six.
They kicked the shit out of us.
Gain five I think it was.
He took the fucking shot and he missed it first.
He goes,
no way.
Carmelo Anthony misses that no fucking way.
And I said,
dude,
that was a big moment for him.
Whether it went in or not.
That was big for him to get over that hurdle and take that fucking shot.
And then meanwhile in the finals,
he hits that killer three to fucking wrap it up that I call him up going dead.
That might have been considering I know nothing of it drives me up the fucking
wall.
I went to a Utah Jazz Boston Celtics game and I fucking said call Versie.
I'm going to this fuck.
The NBA is fixed.
These fucking guys.
At one point you could take somebody's head off,
they're not calling shit,
and then 10 minutes later even look at a guy,
you get a file and then it goes back to taking their fucking heads off.
No biggie.
And it's just like,
these guys are dictating pace.
The fucking shaven points.
I don't know what's going on.
Year later,
fucking mobbed up rough.
If I ever called Versie once about that shit and thrown it in his fucking face.
I never have.
I've to this Robinson Cano fucking horseshit,
and this is the thing,
I don't know.
One person that ever thought Robin Robinson Cano sucked.
I remember as a red sox fan when this dude came up,
all I remember was go like Jesus fucking Christ
cause he went from chuck knob locked,
then they went to fucking Soriano.
That was annoying enough cause I was,
because at that point we had one shit and I was just going,
can they,
can it be somebody who sucks in this tape?
So then they trade Soriana fight on a what?
Right.
And then they bring up Robinson Cano and I was just so fucking eh discouraging.
That's what Robinson can,
was doing.
It was discouraging.
It's like these fucking assholes they got,
they got a guide ever fucking position and they trade a guy and then they bring
another guy up and he's the shit.
That's how I remember the guy coming up.
I don't ever remember like no getting booed and everybody's saying that he's
sucked.
That's what verse he's trying to claim.
And evidently he was the only guy,
not even the Yankee Scouts saw this guy come,
this,
this is going to fucking drive him up the Goddamn wall and it's good.
I'm just trying to help out as podcast.
You know what I mean?
This is like a reverse.
You're like an unknown rappers.
Make a mix tape and they trashed somebody bigger than them so they can move
their way up.
I'm actually helping him.
Um,
I'm raining down,
mix tapes on to his podcast.
Okay.
All right.
Now listen to verse he's podcast and listen to him.
Fucking trash me.
Um,
all right.
I think it,
I think he's quad cash should be called the dude.
I called it a podcast.
I love the guy.
I'm just breaking his balls.
He's fucking hilarious.
And he is one of the best feature acts in the country right now.
So if he's opening for some button up kid,
he's,
he's a,
why can't I compliment my friends?
I just can't fucking do it.
Um,
he's,
he's a looker.
All right,
let's,
uh,
let's plow through here.
I just gave him a window.
That's right.
You can't compliment me and you can't give me credit when he fucking pick
something.
I gave you credit,
Paul,
when he said,
I got to feel and Tom Brady's going to get hurt and he blew out his fucking
knee.
That's your best call.
This Robinson Kenosha.
Okay.
You can stick that a fucking pillow and a and I dunno and do something with it.
Go spoon with it.
Cause I don't give a fuck.
You're not getting credit for it.
You never will get credit for it.
Oh,
by the way,
did you guys see,
I know I'm talking a mile a minute.
I'm sorry.
I'm excited.
I made a fucking dinner for myself and it worked.
All right.
I could exist by myself or rub one out today.
I mean,
it was just a fucking self sustained unit here.
I'm ready for the goddamn apocalypse.
My dog needs a bath.
Look at your itching over there like a maniac.
Um,
uh,
what the fuck was I just talking about?
Oh,
I know.
As says,
I,
oh g I know what I was going to talk about.
I went up to the,
uh,
the Oakland A's facility this weekend.
You know,
cause I'm a giver.
They called me up and they said,
hey bill,
you know what?
We want to give out some root beer floats.
You want to do this to raise awareness for fucking childhood diabetes.
And you know what I did?
I laughed at everybody like everybody else going,
what do you do?
You fucking get you get you given people root beer floats for diabetes and you
don't see the irony in that.
So I got an email.
It says each season fans and media ask about the irony of the Aes root beer
float day supporting juvenile diabetes research.
So here are the facts for when people ask about it.
Uh,
basically eating too much sugar is not a cause or a factor of type one juvenile
diabetes.
Um,
if there's any doctors listening,
let me know if this is right.
Type one diabetes also called juvenile diabetes or insulin dependent diabetes is
a disorder of the body's immune system.
In type one diabetes,
the body does not produce,
does not produce insulin.
Insulin is a hormone that is needed to convert sugar and statues and other food
into energy needed for daily life.
Scientists do not yet know exactly what causes type one diabetes,
but they believe that the auto Amit,
that autoimmune genetic and environmental factors are involved,
well that pretty much covers everything.
People with type one diabetes must inject insulin several times every day or
continually infuse insulin through a pump.
Uh,
eating too much sugar is not a factor.
Limiting sweets,
we'll help people with type one diabetes,
keep their blood sugar under control,
but with the advice of their doctor or nutritionist sweets can't fit into their
meal plan just as they would for people without diabetes.
Um,
so they're,
they're basically suggesting that they can have a cookie too when it's not a
problem provided they haven't eaten a whole box.
Like people who don't have diabetes who do that sometimes.
Evidently.
So what they're saying there,
I don't fucking know.
I got to pass this onto a lawyer or something.
Um,
and there are times when,
when sweets are a must,
if the blood sugar level drops too low suites or juice or soda can be the surest
to raise it and prevent the onset of hypoglycemia.
Uh,
which evidently I guess this low blood sugar,
uh,
with strick adherence to a specific diet and exercise plan and multiple insulin
injections each day based on careful monitoring of blood sugar levels.
A person with type one diabetes can have some control over his blood sugar
levels.
So that's what they say.
Well,
let me ask you this,
the amount of sugar that is in a fucking root beer float,
does anybody need that throughout the course of the day?
Cause I know that,
um,
you know,
some people who have diabetes will carry around a little container of like cake
frosting and when their blood sugar goes gets too low,
like dangerously low,
they'll take it out like a little snifter.
Now they'll just take a little a frosting,
write up their nose.
And that's a fact.
You can go to Wikipedia answer,
you go to Wiki answers and a,
and look that one up.
I don't fucking know.
I all I can tell you this is,
I did a fucking incredible job.
I pat myself on the bat like Paul Versey dose.
This might've been the greatest root beer float ever produced.
I,
um,
I got it down to a science,
science.
I got it down to a fucking science.
This is how you do it.
This is how was fucking up.
I was putting the ice cream in first and then I pour the root bear on and it
would just start foaming up like I was some sort of a mad scientist.
I'm not leaning over to say hello to you cleo.
I'm just leaning over because my back hurts.
All right.
Beat it.
Um,
is it weird that I like dog breath?
You know,
not bad dog breath,
but just in general it doesn't,
I don't fucking know why
I freaked my dog up.
I tell you every once in a while I just grab her by both ears and I yell at her
face.
I fucking love you.
You know,
it's weird.
It's like I can't believe how much I love that fucking dog and uh,
I have problems with that emotion so I don't know how to handle it.
So I have to fucking grab her and have her looking at me like,
what the fuck are you doing?
And then I just yell.
I fucking love you right in her face.
If I told you that before,
I don't give a shit.
I got a fucking hour to fill here.
So anyways,
this is how it,
so the root beer float,
what you want to people is you want to fill your mug about 40% with root beer or
orange soda,
like a lot of people doing kind of make like a cream sick.
A lot of it,
I don't know,
40% and they'd take a nice glob of fucking ice cream and you slammed that fucker
in there,
okay?
You try to let it slide down the side of the glass.
You tilt it like you learn in button at school,
all right?
Because you don't want it to splash because then you're going to have that foam
fucking problem again.
He let it slide.
It's,
this is me.
This is what I did.
People fucking gathering it.
My fucking table was me and this other radio dude up there named Icky who was
looked like a fucking j crew model.
I don't know why his name was Nicky.
I forgot to ask him,
but all the checks fucking loved him and they were looking at me like the
balding redhead that I am,
you know.
And of course like most balding people,
I'm trying harder like that short guy out on the courts,
got his fucking Dick on your leg play in defense and some bullshit pickup game.
Right.
One of those guys.
That's how I was making these root beer floats.
I was fucking killing it.
Saw it's Rafe little bit of your work.
So,
um,
I fucking,
I got it down.
So I would let that thing slide in.
Slide in like a ship being set off to fucking see.
You only do that shit.
I'll,
they don't slide it down a ramp now.
They don't,
they fill the whole fucking thing with water.
What the hell?
Images that I don't fucking know.
Whatever.
Like a fucking pontoon boat in us,
in a,
in a snowstorm.
I don't have an image for it.
Whatever.
Let the fucking,
like quint slid down into the jaws or that shark and he end of jaws,
except he's not kicking and screaming.
He's enjoying it,
you know,
like,
like he wants it to happen.
No.
All right.
Whatever.
So I slide the fucking ice cream down.
There's only a little bit of foam.
And then what you do is you put a little more ice cream in and then you top it
off a little bit of rope here.
Okay.
Maybe take a Napkin.
All right?
You put it on the outside and you hand it to him handled fucking first.
That's what I was doing.
That's the way it went down in case you were wondering.
And then I,
then I,
I,
uh,
what did I do?
Ah,
fuck.
I went out
and,
uh,
went to an Italian restaurant and I'm sitting here sitting there,
ordering is really nice Italian restaurant in San Francisco and I swear to God,
I looked over at two tables over and it was fucking Joe Montana,
Joe Montana Almas fucking,
I almost started shrieking like a girl.
Joe Montana is the Michael Jordan of,
of uh,
of,
of quarterbacks.
He just is,
he's the best I ever fucking saw.
There's nobody near him.
Fuck all these goddamn fantasy football stats guys.
I don't give a shit.
Joe got you to the playoffs and when he got to the playoffs,
Joe one Joe and Forno in fucking Superbowls,
that classic story,
they down against the Bengals.
He sitting there in the huddle during the TV time out,
right?
He just said,
it's John Candy in the crowd.
Right.
Just totally fuck.
Hey,
you know,
whatever.
He's going to go out and throw the ball around when another fucking Superbowl.
Right.
Unfucking believable.
So I was freaking out.
I actually had a buddy of mine asked me,
he goes,
dude,
did you go up to him?
He's asked for a picture.
It's like duty,
Yada.
Your fucking mind.
Fucking Joe Montana.
First of all,
I wouldn't interrupt screech if he was eating and ask him for a God damn photos.
Fucking Joe Montana,
Joe fucking Montana.
I don't,
I wouldn't ask if I fucking,
I want to ask Joe Montana for a photo.
I wouldn't interrupt him for a photo of him.
I just saved them from fucking drowning.
I wouldn't ask him.
I wouldn't impose.
I would fucking Joe Montana.
That is,
that is the biggest,
most legendary fucking athlete I've ever seen.
Or He's up there with.
I,
one time I was in Vegas it,
Micheal Jordan walked through the casino like late,
late,
late at night with like three security guards flank at him.
I'm wearing one of those NBA on the greatest basketball players of all time
suits looking like 1 million bucks.
You did that fucking hoop earring that look like a Goddamn,
I dunno,
like a fucking horse shoe.
Just made out of diamonds hanging out of his ear.
It was,
it's just everybody's stopped even degenerate gamblers.
Everybody just stopped as he fucking walked by.
It was right up there with that and I saw doctor Jay at the espys last year.
Those were my big three.
It gotta be.
Those are the three biggest guys I ever saw.
It's fucking unreal.
Joe Montana,
I just kept looking over at,
I sent it to my waiter
when he came over.
I was just like,
is that fucking Joe Montana?
And he was all geeking out going,
yeah,
it is.
How's I called fucking Joe Montana?
I said the f word like 1515 you know what is about Joe Montana fight,
aside from being the shit,
when he retired,
he just kind of disappeared.
He didn't go on ESPN.
He didn't do any of that shit.
I'm for the first time in years,
he's finally doing some national commercials with that,
you know,
hey look a little,
these new fucking sneakers,
I'm going to help your old feet,
whatever,
whatever the fuck they are.
Is that the worst impression of a commercial ever?
Hey d the fuck is that.
Hey,
look at these sneakers,
whatever.
So I think that adds to its mystique.
He kind of left like Johnny Carson,
Johnny Carson signed off.
That was it.
He did one Letterman.
I think that was it.
He did one Letterman thing and then that was it called in the tonight show.
One time I think when they were doing celebrity in a sack or some shit like
that,
or he made fun of it.
I do remember that.
But he just left with clash.
Joe Montana did the same thing.
You know,
he's not out there with some NBC Pea coat,
right?
Just to know what the judge got a dude.
He's not doing that.
Okay?
Joe Doesn't need to sit there and analyze.
He knows what's going to happen.
He's fucking Joe Montana a dead it.
I'm done with you guys.
Guy was still in phenomenal shape.
You know,
I was the shit.
It was the fucking shit.
So that was my week.
I gave out root beer floats the Oakland A's.
Jesus Christ.
Man,
if you want to go to a throwback fucking stadium,
you got to go to the Oakland A's stadium,
man.
And you know what?
You're going to realize how truly fat this country has got.
And I'm not talking about their fans.
I'm talking about how small the corridor is when you walk out to get food.
Um,
and just the way they used to build the stadiums,
the way they used to build the stadiums.
You know,
nowadays you can order a fucking hot dog,
you know,
while you're rubbing one out,
taking a piss,
still watching the Goddamn game,
you still have a great sight lines everywhere.
This thing man,
you just walk in and you're,
you're,
you're like in a bunker.
You have no idea what's going on.
There's like a kitchen TV like 30 yards away,
like,
like hanging from the ceiling.
Right.
That fucking Ken Stabler donated to it.
That's basically what happened.
And um,
that's what I always realize when I go to the old stadiums is how truly fat this
country has got.
You know,
I guess they will,
they were smaller back then,
weren't they?
They were shorter.
So why a bunch of little people just waddle into what a fucker.
Would the sealants be that high?
I Dunno.
I was like claustrophobic walking through the shit.
I'm just like,
this needs to be at least like another,
like fucking 10 feet wider.
It was like the,
the where the where the Oakland Coliseum,
whatever the fuck they call it.
That is the antithesis to Yankee stadium.
If you guys,
if you,
I don't know if you've been to the new Yankee stadium,
it's weird.
It's like breathtaking and grownup up Goddie all at the same time.
Sometimes you,
you,
you walk around a corner,
you see something as like,
oh my God,
it takes you back to like 1929.
You think Ruth and Gehrig are gonna come walking around,
you're going to hear their cleats and then you look to your left and then
there's some guy behind glass cutting up steaks.
Like,
oh,
look at all the money.
You know,
it's really fucking stupid.
Um,
that's what,
that's what happens when I,
whenever I go to new Yankee Stadium,
I either think about Lou Gehrig and the old school Yankees,
or I think of that pizza hut commercial where that fucking white trash whore was
eating the pasta going.
And she did,
but she didn't know that it was pizza hut or Domino's or whatever.
And they were like,
what do you think about it?
She's like,
oh my God,
it's so decadent.
Pizza,
hot pasta,
decadent.
Really.
Um,
speaking of corporate entities,
it's time for a fucking commercial.
Here we go.
Commercial.
All right?
There's only two this week.
Everybody,
you know,
some kind of actually said,
a commercials are only 30 seconds long on TV.
Why don't you get on it?
Are they as enter fucking tanning as these are?
I don't think they are,
sir.
And then not only 30.
What about those infomercials?
Maybe I'm doing a little mini infomercial.
You ever think about that?
You know to,
why don't you just fast forward through it?
You fucking moron.
Alright.
Advertisement number one,
Amazon.
If you're a,
if you're going to buy something online,
you want to support the Monday morning podcast,
ah,
this is a great way to do it.
And you're also supporting the,
uh,
the wounded warrior project,
right?
You go to my podcast bill bird.com.
You Click on the podcast page and a,
then you click on the Amazon banner.
This is just,
if you're going to Amazon,
all right?
Just stop on my podcasts.
Go on there.
Once you go onto amazon.com you don't have to do anything.
And then,
uh,
you want to buy something,
go ahead and buy it.
And,
uh,
they,
they kick a certain percentage back to me and then I take 10% of that and I
rounded up to the nearest fucking hundred and a,
I pass that onto the troops.
All right.
That's a great way to help out my podcast and a great way to support the troops
all in one to one.
One like that guy shampoo that has got the shampoo and the conditioner right in
it.
Right?
All right,
the next one,
this is it.
This is the last one for the week.
A game.
fly.com.
You got 18,000 video games available.
Do you play video games?
Is that what you do?
Is that what you're doing over there?
You play a little video game.
What are you going to game?
fly.com because I know you don't have 8,000 video games.
I know you don't gamefly fly.com does.
You've got 8,000 video games.
They'll mail them right to your house.
We can sit there and your pajamas rubbing you balls as you pay for him.
Uh,
actually you don't,
you have to pay for him.
It's a 15 day,
a free day free trial.
Okay.
They'll mail them to you or send them right to your frigging PC.
A monthly fees are a fraction of what?
A new game cost.
They got stuff.
It works for playstation,
Xbox,
we,
and even on your Pc.
So for Monday and Monday morning podcast listeners,
get a free two desk,
15 day free trial.
It's a $23 value by going to www.gamefly.com/ [inaudible] or you go through the
banner ad on the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com.
There you go.
All right.
That's it wasn't that painless,
wasn't it?
Painless man.
Bitching about fucking commercials.
Um,
Oh,
you know what?
I tweeted about some girl,
I'm,
I'm too old to know who the fuck she is.
MMM.
Now what the fuck did I do with all the podcast shit.
I'm the worst.
I got all this shit here.
Every,
and you know what's gonna be the last one that I click on?
You know it's going to be,
where is it?
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's not that.
You know at some point I really should just hit pause.
Shinai you guys.
You know what?
I'm not doing this to hang on a second.
All right,
I'm back dude.
I gotta tell you something.
I hate this.
This is the reverse commercial.
The new Mac book pro can suck a Dick.
I fucking hate this thing.
It's unfucking believable.
I knew how to use a laptop before I bought this thing.
Now I don't,
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
I never closed the window with the fuck did it go dude?
Do you know something that that cunt that's in your iPhone,
that Ciri Bitch,
do you know that like the dates sit there and like gather all the information
that you talk about to that bitch so she can air quote help you out better that
I cloud shit.
You just given them all the stuff that you do like did,
they're a bunch of fucking creeps over there.
They really are at Apple.
A bunch of fucking voyeuristic fucking Weirdos.
They got that whole j Edgar Hoover vibe going on over there.
Every fucking thing you do.
Like they're peaking in their fucking nerds.
They don't know how to get laid.
So now what they're doing is this standing outside the window of everybody in
this fucking country,
that Dick in their hand,
we're trying to figure out what the fuck you doing.
How is that legal?
Why don't they bring it up?
This is some legal Mumbo jumbo that I automatically agreed to.
The second I fucking bought this phone.
I don't talk to that robot bitch at all.
I cut her out of my life.
You know that fucking John Malcovich just giggling like a little God damn
schoolgirl seven a just having a great fucking time with noise.
The hell out of me.
Um,
all right.
Upcoming shows.
I'm going to be in uh,
the inland empire,
Ontario,
California,
June 29th,
30th and July 1st with Cleveland,
Ohio's own Jason Law head and uh,
Kevin Shea.
Kevin Shay is going to be out there.
Uh,
could meet the Hampton Beach Ballroom Casino 14th and the Newport Yachting
Festival Center or whatever the fuck it is.
July 15th and I'll be a Carolines in New York City from July 26th through the
29th and I'll be making a beeline to the opiate Anthony Program to,
uh,
to defend my honor after Joe Derosa mercilessly evidently trashed me last Friday
on the show.
Okay.
Now I know that I shouldn't get mad at him.
This isn't Joe.
This is his addiction.
All right?
The sensation.
He had a,
he had a nice run,
you know,
his album sales start a fallen off.
He got,
he got the sickness.
Alrighty.
He was exhausted.
He went away and now he's coming back and he's lashing out at the people that
helped him out in this business.
Okay.
Fucking Joe to Rosa taking swings at me while I'm still sleeping,
taking fucking pot shots at me while I'm fucking trying to get my God damn
beauty sleep.
You know,
isn't that exactly what you'd expect from a shoulder list?
Half Egyptian fucking son of a bitch like Joe to Rosa?
Uh,
that motherfucker.
He's God a God damned motherfucker.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's get with the question here.
Uh,
obsessed friend or as I read it the first time,
obese friend,
obsessed friend.
Hey Bill.
First and foremost,
I like your podcast.
Thank you.
Ah,
I wanted to get your opinion on something.
One of my male friends.
Do you have female friends?
I don't,
I don't get how that works.
I really don't get how that works.
I ain't had such a funny conversation.
Wow.
Jesus was,
I get going.
I have this conversation with this guy one time and we were talking about guys
like women who have guys,
friends,
straight guy friends
and we will say that we didn't like it.
Like I don't like Nia to have guy friends.
I don't,
I don't like it.
I don't like these guys fucking hanging around.
And this guy summed it up perfectly.
He goes to types of guys,
hang out our friends with women,
gay guys and guys trying to fuck that woman and just exactly it.
He put it a little more colorful in that.
All right.
But that's exactly how I feel.
You know,
I don't have any female friends.
I have,
I have a few,
but it's like deaf.
I'd seen him at comedy clubs.
That's it.
We don't fucking hang out though.
You know,
like,
oh,
I'll,
you know,
let's,
I'll come by,
pick you up.
Let's go to the movies.
If I'm doing that with the,
I'm trying to fuck you.
You know,
there's no like,
what am I sit around and talk about reality TV's or whatever.
Can I be more condescending?
The females,
whatever the fuck it is you guys talk about.
Um,
anyways,
sometimes guys I think have female friends so they can fuck their friends.
I don't know.
I've never,
uh,
I never been able to do that.
I just like,
it's on the tape.
This is you.
You know why I'm here.
All right.
I'm not here to fucking borrowing and bracelet,
you know,
do you know those guys,
the guys that get the most goddamn ass,
other than just those fucking type a fucking,
we just,
they just got that thing that makes girls fall all over themselves.
I'm not talking to them about those guys who just,
you know,
at 13,
they get bang,
a 28 year old hardy.
I'm not talking about those fucking guys.
You know,
grow fucking mustache already.
You know those guys like banging a teacher and shit and it's like no big deal to
them.
And I'm talking about them.
I'm just talking like regular fucking dudes who had to figure out a way to,
to,
to get some those fucking dudes who are straight and they do that androgynous
thing where they start borrowing chicks close at chicks like that.
It's fucking over.
It's over.
You don't,
when he got a little Steven Tyler in your tank,
you know,
um,
anyways,
what am I trying to say here?
Yeah.
You weren't like scarves and you're,
you accessorize as you address it.
You know,
there's something about it.
I like God,
I love that.
What is that?
Is that maze,
but it's amazing.
It's amazing what corn is made out of.
I'm trying,
I was trying to think,
what does that light blue shit that they have?
Yeah.
Mexico teal.
Well,
what the fuck do you call it?
Uh,
as tech,
uh,
Arapaho.
Sorry,
we annihilated you.
Here's a casino.
What the fuck is that shit called?
Okay.
Oh God dammit.
No.
Gives a shit.
Um,
white guy pretending to be a cowboy.
What the fuck is that?
Pretending you have a ranch.
Um,
this,
anyways,
where the fuck was it?
One of my male friends who I've been friends with for a long time,
maybe this is a check writing it.
Who knows?
Met this girl about a year ago and she has since become good friends with my
entire group of friends.
This friend,
this friend has become obsessed.
Okay.
The first person you're talking about now,
that's what I'm going,
I'm just,
that's how I'm reading this has been your friend has become obsessed with this
girl and makes it unintentionally obvious to the world that he would do anything
to be with her.
He makes every possible attempt he can to be around her to do stuff for her and
even helps her pay your bills.
Well,
I can tell you one thing.
This dude is never fucking this girl.
What kind of fucking approaches that,
you know,
that's like giving away merchandise and then when all by the way,
that was 50 bucks there are in the car driving away.
All right.
Would you got to do is hold that.
Do you know hike people?
This is how,
this is how you bang a girl like this.
Do you know you have a watch a hockey fight?
They don't stand face to face anymore.
What they do is they stand sideways,
Grab Jersey and they cocked a fucking hand back,
right.
And the standard sideways,
you know,
and you've got that close shoulder so that guy can't really get you with
anything if you're doing it right.
And then if he goes to throw the fucking overhand right,
you're out of his range.
Unless he's fucking really tall.
But I'm just saying generally speaking,
that's how you do it with this girl.
Okay.
You get your hand on a fucking shoulder and then everything she wants,
you hold it away from her so she can't get it.
And it's in between what she wants at her.
What's in between it is you and your Dick.
Okay.
That's how I,
that's how you got to do it.
That's called the Carsello.
Um,
I hope that made sense anyways.
and he'll do anything.
He's paying her fucking bills.
The annoying part is he will not be straight up with any of us friends and say
how he truly wants to be with her.
He will only say she's hot.
Uh,
yeah,
I can tell you was banging this girl,
the guy who's not doing all that shit.
Um,
anyways,
she is aware about how he feels in an attempt to steer him away.
She says stuff like,
you're like my brother and will not do anything to make him think that he's even
the slightest has the slightest chance of anything.
I'll fuck this.
Fuck that.
All right.
Oh,
but she'll accept him paying her bills.
She's using the guide now.
This guy's a jackass.
This guy is a jackass.
Okay.
He is setting himself up to be fucking used.
Oh,
you're like a boyfriend.
That's what she does.
I mean,
you're like a brother.
She's saying that right after he pays her fucking bills.
I bet she doesn't say that before,
you know.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I,
I think this is,
this is obviously his fault.
He's putting himself in this situation,
but she's kind of a Douche for a,
for using them like that.
I that I,
that really fucking annoys me
that that really says something about this other person.
I would never fucking do that
to somebody.
Lead somebody on like that.
Why would you do that?
Because you are kind of leave them alone in a little way.
Oh,
what have you taken advantage of?
This stupid fucking puppy love that they have for you.
You know,
if somebody comes up to you and they're really into you and you're not into
them,
you know,
it's Kinda your job to stay the fuck away from him.
So they forget about you.
That's the gentleman thing to do.
You know?
If they give you a gift,
you just take it and you go,
hey,
you see that and you'll fucking throw it across the parking lot.
All right.
Just get it over with.
Rip The bandaid off.
He just be mean to him.
Something he could get him the fuck away from me.
All right?
But you don't just keep being nice to them.
Keep hanging around them and fucking letting them pay your bill.
I guess you guys have the same group of friends,
but you know,
she's just be like,
look,
stop.
Pay My fucking bills.
Because at some point I feel like you,
you feel you're going to feel like you can fuck me and that ain't happening.
All right?
So you get that egg,
get that stupid fucking look off your face.
It ain't happening.
I don't like you fuck off.
Okay.
See at the reunion,
um,
she sometimes even cracks jokes when he's not around,
uh,
about his never ending attempts to win her over.
Uh,
this girl is a cunt.
It's getting to the point where it's pitiful and I want to tell him to stop
being such a pussy and realize it isn't going to happen and move on.
At the same time.
He's a good friend and I want to be respectful.
Uh,
and I get it.
She's a cool chick and she's hot and he's trying to get it,
uh,
get it in.
What,
what would you recommend?
Sit back and continue watching the desperation.
It'd be straight up and try and talk some sense into him.
Ah,
this is always a hard fucking thing
cause you could be like,
you know,
fuck her,
she's using your,
or whatever.
They ain't going to happen.
And then they end up together and then you're the Douche and you get froze out.
Yeah.
MMM.
But I,
I think in this case,
and this kid doesn't have a prayer,
he's just,
he's not even a man to wear at this point.
He's just showing that he's dumb,
that he can be used and that he's not gonna not nearly make as much an hour as
he should because he's a jackass.
That that's what he's showing her.
So,
um,
okay.
Yeah.
She just,
you know,
at the very least critique the guy's approach to be like,
look,
you want to fuck this girl.
Just,
you know?
Yeah.
Just ignore it.
Don't ignore it.
Just be like,
Hey,
what's going on?
Just be your fucking self.
Like,
talk to other people,
you know,
go hit on some mother fucking hot girl in front of us,
some shit like that.
I've said this shit before.
That's what you do.
You know,
go out,
start working out.
Do you know,
take care of yourself.
Get a little fucking spring in your step.
And also what the fuck's he doing?
All of a sudden he's not paying attention to me and that's going to tap into
her.
Oh my God,
am I,
am I not hot anymore?
That that fear,
they have a fear that all fucking hot chicks have the day.
They're not going to be hot anymore.
You know when they stayed out there too long,
okay?
You know,
you got to tap into that shit,
but then you,
you're playing a fucking game.
You know this,
this douchebag,
he's,
he fucking loves therefore on an asshole.
Okay?
Oh,
you know,
why don't you just say to one night,
just be like,
dude,
how long are you gonna fucking chase this chick?
Why are you paying your bills?
You set yourself up like a fucking SAP.
Do you want to bang this girl?
Stop treating her like she's fucking mother Theresa has disgusting.
That's the wrong one to end up treating her like she's fucking Mary the Virgin.
Fucking marry you as a kid.
Give me a break,
right?
Oh,
would I fucking give her shit if I ever saw,
if I were ever came walking down the street,
my sandals and my role back in the day and I saw the virgin merit.
Raylee
how did it happen?
How did it happen?
Yeah,
how did,
how did a real,
you just woke up when you were pregnant?
Well,
congratulations Mary.
You got roof eat.
All right.
Don't take a shower.
Go down and get yourself fucking swab and let's figure out who did it.
Wow.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Uh,
let's regroup from that one.
All right.
Let you know that that isn't my fault.
That's some fucking shit.
That's,
that's cause he does have this God damn question.
All right,
well,
you know what dude,
if you want to tell them,
just fucking tell them.
Just tell them if there was a friend,
I can't sit here watching you keep running up trying to kick the football and
watching to take it away.
Okay?
She doesn't fucking respect you.
Don't say that.
Don't say anything of that.
The girls said,
because then he's going to say it to her and then she's going to give you that
fucking,
you know,
that look that girls do when they're mad,
where they make their eyes like really small.
You know,
sometimes they have their mouth hanging open when they do it.
Like,
you know,
you don't,
you don't want to deal with that.
Um,
did I even give you advice?
I don't remember.
All right,
should I kick my girlfriend's Dad's ass?
Hey Bill.
I remember giving advice to a guy about whether or not he should kick his
neighbor's ass while I'm in a similar situation,
only in evolves my girlfriend's father.
I'm 22 years old and I am a first lieutenant in the U s army and I live in
Colorado.
Oh,
Jesus.
He up there in Greeley if fort whatever with the bad smell day.
Huh?
Could you stop slaughtering cows?
We can't breathe.
Um,
or they steer,
I dunno.
I've been with my girl for a little under a year now and her father has not been
a problem up until now.
Her parents are extremely religious.
Oh,
oh.
Don't play this podcast.
Especially that last part and they're always trying to get me and my girl to go
to mass with them.
When I first met her,
Oh,
when I first met her dad,
he seemed like a good shit.
Good Shit.
This guy's east coast seemed like a good shit kit.
We are both gun nuts.
So the entire time I was around him we talked about guns,
no conflicts at all.
The second time I saw him I was in my,
uh,
my uniform and while we were talking about whatever name shit we were talking
about,
he slipped into the conversation.
You know,
just because you're in the army,
you know,
just because you are in the army does not scare me at all.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
That is weird.
Just cause you were in the army.
That doesn't scare me at all.
I raised an eyebrow at this,
but I let it slide.
I hope you filed that in the back of your head.
That's a weird one.
This is about eight months ago.
Fast forward to about two days ago.
I'm currently moving out of the military housing in Fort Carson here in Colorado
Spring and I'm fixing to move up to Denver to people on buying the house from,
we're still moving out.
So I had to stay at a friend's house and my girl was staying at her parents'
house one night.
We went out to dinner and we stayed out til around 11
and made out after we ate.
Okay.
People,
this is what I'm talking about where I don't need to every fucking detail.
Let's just get to the point here.
Um,
I made no effort to fuck this girl because I know her parents will start foaming
at the mouth if I do.
Uh,
but looks like I don't have to,
she fell asleep in my car on the way back,
so I had to carry her.
I was doing so well reading wasn't I,
she asleep in the car on the way back,
so I had to carry her to her inside.
Okay.
Inside the houses that we were trying to say.
Uh,
when her mom opened the door,
she looked extremely nervous and my girls' dad was sitting in a chair just
staring at me as they walked in and took the girl to the guests from,
dude,
why didn't you just fucking wake her up?
When I went back downstairs,
her dad was waiting for me at the door before I could leave.
He put,
he put his hand in front of me and said,
I want a word with you outside.
This is never good.
Whenever it says I want a word with you outside,
um,
we both went outside.
He outright asked me,
did you fuck my daughter?
I told him no,
but he replied,
you're a God damn liar.
No one stays out that long without fucking,
oh my God.
Was he wearing a wife beater with his old man chest sagging a little bit.
I reassured him I did not fuck his daughter and before I left,
he looked at me in the eyes with his nose about touching Mies and said,
if I find out you ever have sex with my daughter,
you don't even want to know what's going to happen to you.
I blankly stared at him for about 10 seconds and walked away to my truck and
drove away.
I'm now living in Denver with my girl and I'm getting calls every day from her
dad asking what we're doing and what our plans for the day or yesterday,
he called up and asked the same old stupid ass question.
And my girl told them we were planning to go out and see a movie yesterday.
He came over to my house without his wife,
since I answered the door,
he told me to step outside and he asked me once again if I fucked his daughter.
Okay.
In almost identical conversation,
identical conversation,
sued.
Uh,
but this time I noticed he had a sidearm on him
do this is,
this is okay.
This is going beyond my,
uh,
my abilities here.
Buddy,
when he was wearing a jacket with the shoulder host it,
but he's so fucking fat that a pistol insanely contrast with this round yoga
ball body form he wants against said,
he told me that I don't want to even know what will happen if I fuck his
daughter.
Bill,
I need your advice.
What should I do about this prick?
I'm pretty sure that this guy has no idea that I went to ranger school and I had
been trained to shove a knife and another man's neck with a not a Blairite are
right,
are right to what the fuck?
Uh,
this is what you need.
MMM.
I Dunno what you need to do,
dude.
This is beyond me.
Okay.
This,
this sounds like the beginning of one of those murders,
these murder things.
MMM.
I think you to,
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck to do here.
Don't listen to my advice here cause I'm gonna end up getting sued.
This one's too deep.
You don't need to kick this guy's ass.
You don't need to do anything like that.
I think you almost need to go to the cops.
Does this guy have a license to carry?
Why the fuck is he sitting there with the pistol and it keeps having this open
ended thing.
Dude,
this is for this guy's fucking nuts,
man.
This guy sounds like he's crazy and,
uh,
I dunno,
this is easy for me to say cause I don't have any feelings in this thing.
I would fucking say,
you know what?
Um,
you need to go back and move back home with your parents and you need to live
with them.
And uh,
when your dad can accept the fact that you're an adult and you're going to do
what you want to do,
give me a call.
But until then,
I don't need some guy coming up to me making veiled threats with the fucking
side are all right.
I'm not looking to get shot in the fucking head.
And that's the thing,
dude.
I know you're a ranger and that type of thing.
But the thing about a gun is that makes everybody tough.
Okay?
You can fucking kill Bruce Lee with the gun.
So,
uh,
I,
you definitely do not want to go,
you know,
Steven Seagal on this shit.
Like,
I,
I don't Dunno,
this sounds to me like I would get out of that relationship,
tell her to go home and just say,
listen,
uh,
your dad is not ready for you to be in an adult relationship and I'm not ready
to die or get shot at or whatever the fuck it is he has planned.
I am going to stay here and,
uh,
you know,
enjoy my life without fat men coming up to me asking me what the fuck I'm doing
with the women in my life.
Good Luck and God blessed and it's on to Chicago.
Let's win there.
That's what the fuck I would do.
But like I said,
I don't,
don't listen to me on that one eye that is beyond.
Okay.
Yeah.
Dude,
that's a,
that's,
that's the whole,
that's whole other level shit here.
Yeah.
It's guys don't send me and shit like that.
That's,
that's creepy man.
That's uh,
okay.
Uh,
yeah,
that's it.
All right.
Okay.
Let's,
let's move on.
Hey,
breakup advice.
All right,
let's try to break the tension here.
Uh,
I'm 27 and just broke up with my girlfriend at two years.
We took a break for about three months last summer,
got back together in September and had been going together ever since.
Yeah.
Um,
let's read that again.
I was too busy thinking of the other thing.
I'm 27 just broke up with my girlfriend at two years.
We took a break for about three months last summer,
got back together in September and vain bend together ever since.
I'm going to guess that this,
you're going to find out she fucks somebody in those three months.
Uh,
we've been arguing a lot over the past two months or so,
but it's all about bullshit.
Nothing serious.
Just little nagging things that get us all worked up.
And then it turns into a much bigger fight about how we don't see the same.
We don't see the same way on priorities and key relationship points.
Yeah.
You guys,
you broke up,
you got lonely,
you got back together.
If this happens,
this is like a,
the breakups,
the tsunami,
and then this is the aftershock.
And finally for the second wave,
uh,
one fight a couple of weeks ago.
Actually it was because she thought she left the stove on.
I said,
no,
it's fine.
She says,
well,
you don't know for sure.
And then an x escalated from there.
I thought that shit only happens on bad sitcoms now.
We've never done anything bad like cheat or be abusive as far as you know,
towards each other at all.
And when things are good,
we're totally in love.
We have all the same interest and enjoy doing things together tremendously.
Unfortunately,
it's only around 60% of the time.
The other 40% were kind of on edge with each other.
So she ended up breaking up with me about two weeks ago after a stupid drunk
fight when we got home from the bar to Am.
Her words were,
we're just not working.
Uh,
now since then she's been commenting slash liking my picks and status on social
networks and I am in me when we're at work.
Yeah.
This girl is,
she just,
she's not ready to just go walk through the pain by herself.
So she keeps doing it like this.
She goes,
I even got drunk late last night,
phone call then hang up the other night.
Okay.
Oh you did that.
Uh,
she was,
she was the one to break it off too.
She claims she,
she missed me like crazy,
but she just doesn't know what to do.
I said,
we either cut the bullshit and move forward or stop talking completely.
She hasn't replied to me since that last thing I said,
I really do love this chick and imagine,
imagine us spending a very long time together at this point.
Uh,
I'm almost positive she feels the same way as well,
but should I stop being a pussy and just move along?
I'm not sure if these things can be worked out or we both adjust our attitudes
or if they really are,
is a more serious problem in the big picture of relationship.
Any feedback?
What else?
Um,
uh,
I dunno.
Do you know what to just take three months for use?
Fuck itself?
Three,
three,
six months.
Just get away from it.
Don't talk to her six,
eight months if you're still fucking,
I don't know.
I don't know how long have you guys,
we went off for like two years.
It's going to take like,
it's gonna take like six,
eight months to kind of,
you know,
it's sucks.
If you love somebody,
it's going to take that long just to kind of get it going again.
But,
um,
okay,
look,
dude,
if you're going to marry this chick someday,
you know,
why not go out and bang a bunch of broads now before we get back together with
her and it's going to be her call because she fucking broke up with you.
I always have the same advice.
Just fucking focused on yourself,
you know,
get in great shape,
go out,
go chat up.
Some fucking girls you think are out of your league,
who knows?
You might meet a better one,
who knows who the fuck knows.
But,
uh,
at this point she's,
you know,
I,
I w I would definitely,
uh,
you just going to keep,
when you break up with somebody,
you got to get away from him or are you just going to keep part in each other
and um,
yeah.
You know,
I,
I don't advise,
advise going out getting plast or need a bunch of shit food and becoming a
fucking depressed tub of shit.
Uh,
you know,
jerking off with Kim,
KFC containers around it.
Don't do that.
Go the other way.
All right,
go the other way.
I Dunno dude.
Just go do some shit you couldn't do when you were fucking with her.
You know what I mean?
Go take a road trip.
Go,
go to a fucking baseball stadium.
You wanted to go to go do some fun,
dumb shit.
Whatever the fuck you want to do.
Learn how to ride a motorcycle.
Some fucking cool guy.
Shit.
Just go have a good fucking time to something going on all star game.
You know,
go out to Vegas,
go to that fucking whore ranch,
whatever the fuck you want to do.
Go do some shit like that.
And then,
you know,
if you still give a fuck about her and you know,
by the time the next election,
uh,
that I,
I dunno,
I dunno what to tell you
that then,
then figure it out from there.
But at this point I would stay away from each other.
She stopped hurting each other.
Right.
Convincing my girlfriend to get a dog.
All right.
This is a nice show and a billion person.
I been live with my girlfriend for about a month plus now.
It's seriously the greatest relationship I've ever been in.
Really?
In a month.
Yeah.
You fucking every day.
Why wouldn't it be awesome?
Um,
and see,
I just took all the joy out of that.
Maybe you found the one,
I don't know.
In order to take this relationship to the next level,
I would really like us to get a great Dane.
Oh,
sorry.
I just had to take a look here.
You have to live with this girl.
You just moved in for a month.
Yeah.
And now you want to get a great Dane.
Everything's going great.
You fucking like rabbits.
And now you want to live with a little horse.
All right.
I would really like us to get a great day from all great Dane owners.
I hear they are the laziest dog,
so they don't require a ton of work in comparison to terror.
Terrorists,
for example,
do,
but they take up the whole apartment.
Okay.
All right.
They take a shit the size of that fucking age Salami they have hanging in those
fucking Italian restaurants.
You know,
you've got to pick it up with a fucking hefty bag.
I don't know to each his own the main reason why I need her approvals because
she'll have to participate in the working in the work of taking care of the dog.
Most of my work involves me being gone for 12 to 14 hours a day at to you outta
your mind while her job is nine to five how do you suggest I convinced this
woman to agree to get a dog?
Dude,
don't get a dog.
Don't,
that's not fair to the dog.
Okay.
You're basically never there and she works nine to five.
You're,
you're,
you're not in a place right now to get a dog.
Dogs need attention.
They're pack animals.
They like laying around with you.
All right?
It's hard enough for them for free to leave for an eight hour day.
Um,
okay.
That's not fair to the dog,
man.
Yeah.
Um,
it's great that you're a dog lover,
but,
uh,
and also I don't think it's good for your relationship.
You just moved in.
He just figuring out who does what.
You having a good time and then you got to add this fucking thing that's going
to come in.
It's probably going to be a puppy.
It's going to be shitting all over the place.
You're going to,
you're going to kill you utopia.
I think it's a bad move,
Dude.
I think it's great to get a dog.
It's the greatest fucking thing I ever did.
I love having a dog,
but I waited till I had a schedule,
you know,
and I,
and I was with the right person and all that type of shit and I didn't figure
that out a month.
So,
uh,
I don't know,
Dude.
I think that's,
that might be throwing a giant fucking wrench in your situation.
Uh,
but let me know how it works out.
All right.
Overrated.
Underrated,
underrated.
Uh,
if you guys want to send the overweight and underweight,
this is something else that you also send to that,
right?
That uh,
that email address that I uh,
I I gave you earlier.
I'm underrated.
Taking a punch from your girlfriend's ex.
Uh,
I was out at a bar with my lady in some of my lady and some other friends.
I come back from a bar to see this guy yelling at her friends.
So I Mosey on over and make sure nothing's going down while I'm looking at the
Tigers game on TV.
He takes a swing at me and I took it like a champ.
That's the end of the story,
Dude.
You got to write me back.
I got to know what happened.
Overrated bouncers.
Oh,
here we go.
They grabbed both of us before I could get a swinging,
but oh well taking his punch.
Got My girl to do anything I wanted that night and it made me look like a bad
ass when the punch didn't faze me.
Ah,
that's hilarious.
See that.
See what happens.
See what happens when you get jealous over a woman.
You go over your punch,
somebody in the face,
it doesn't even hurt.
And then he's banging that chicken the ass.
There's a lesson right there.
There's one to grow on,
underrated.
A cleaning your car,
clean that shit up.
There's nothing worse than getting to a friend's car and having you having to
place your feet between two buckets of water.
Two months old of water bottles and coffee cups.
Absolutely.
I recently heard a girl on Ari Shaffir.
Yep.
Podcast.
Uh,
you guys gotta check that out by the way.
That's another one of my favorites.
Uh,
Ari spelled Ari Shaffir.
A podcast.
Say there's that girls.
Take that as a sign of how clean your bedroom is.
I think it's true.
One of my buddies' cars look at it looks like a recycling center and his bedroom
looks like it hosted a motley crew after.
Except that's not,
except that's not cool.
And there was no,
there was no party.
Uh,
yeah,
absolutely.
I fucking can't stay in a woman with a messy car.
You know,
you get an,
Oh my God,
I have a cat on Psi and he got cat hair all over you.
You know,
and then you see what they ate for the last six fucking weeks.
It's disgusting or a,
and I think when girls have like fucking half their wardrobe,
it's just,
it's disgusting.
You know what I mean?
And I imagine like a guy's filthy car has got to be even fucking worse.
And I,
I bet that's even more of a turn off for a woman just because of the way we're
set up physically.
You know,
I just look at him like us.
Gross,
disgusting.
I don't want a banger.
You know,
they gotta look at your bill and we go,
this guy's disgusting.
He's going to enter my body.
All right.
Overrated.
Drinking coffee to stay awake.
Yeah.
You might wake up a bit,
but you function like an asshole and your breath smells like an ashtray.
Eat an apple and Google for a run.
Um,
that's how you wake yourself up.
Jesus Christ.
That's pretty healthy.
All right,
youtube a video of the week.
I actually just watched the first 10 minutes of this.
This is fucking awesome.
If you guys want to watch a great documentary,
it's a documentary about bouncers.
Uh,
we'll have this on the uh,
the uh,
the FM podcast page.
You can click on it.
Uh,
it's actually just called bounce your documentary part one and a.
You get to see these guys tell their stories.
You know,
some of them are smart,
some of them are meat heads.
I think they have a nice balance.
Some guys don't want to get into a fight.
Some guys who like,
one guy's just like,
sometimes I just want somebody to say something just to give me an excuse.
He's like fucking squeeze in his fists together,
sweating and Shit.
It's a great one.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you everybody for listening.
Once again,
let me give out that email again
just so you have it,
cause I haven't given it out in a long fucking time.
Uh,
all right.
The it once again,
if you would like to email the podcast,
send your overrated,
underrated,
and all that bullshit asked me advice,
whatever you want to do.
Uh,
it's bill at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
All right.
That's it.
Hope you guys have a great weekend.
Uh,
look at me.
Get the podcast up on time.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.